Tears of peace.
[Music]
What is that?
I forgot things.
[Music]
Heat. Hey, Heat.
Christian.
[Music]
Hello.
Hello. I like to say it nice and long
sometimes. It is so wonderful to see
your happy shining faces today. Um,
thanks for showing up. Hello to our
online friends as well. Um, I'm glad you
are there. Um, Mindy's grabbing me now,
uh, because she's late, but we're not
going to talk about that. Um, okay.
Couple of announcements as we get
started tonight now that you're here.
One, um, there is an opportunity to
build a wheelchair ramp for some people
in need. Uh, we are gathering volunteers
for that. I'm on the volunteer list and
now I have a lot of bass in my voice and
I'm going to step back to see if that
changes it.
Maybe better. We're going to keep
talking. No, don't keep talking, Gary.
I'm not that gifted.
Um, okay. Well, that seems solved for
the moment, so I'm going to stay here.
Um, wheelchair ramp. I have signed up.
Please come join me. I have hammers and
nails and things, but somebody has the
the knowhow. I just have the muscle. So,
um, everybody has muscles. I think it's
a great thing to come and do. Um, two,
summer is next Saturday. So, if you've
not signed up, please do so today via
the QR code. Um, it is a great chance
for your kids to come and get some
wonderful experiences throughout a day.
They will probably wind up very tired.
Um, which can benefit you if you're a
parent, I hear. Um,
three, if tonight you feel uneasy or
tension or something and you need
something to help do that, we have an
accessibility bucket over at the little
table. Uh, we ask that you use it. Has
coloring sheets, headphones, etc. Um,
because this is not always an easy
environment for everybody. So, if you
need that, please feel free to use it.
Just return it at the end of service.
Um, and I think that's it for the
moment. So with that
[Music]
now we exit the kingdom of noise, hurry
and productivity.
We enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness and simplicity.
Shared space, a place for prayer,
worship and adoration. A place to behold
Christ. Revelation of God, heartbeat of
creation.
Allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
Thank you.
If you guys want to stand with us,
get our pads going here. I wanted to
just give a quick little, I don't know,
window into a worship leader's thought
process tonight. before we start our
set. Um, at least this worship leader,
which is probably a little stranger than
most, but um, when I'm planning a set,
there just sometimes it feels like this,
you know, sometimes you're just kind of
like doing the thing that you do week
after week and asking God to, you know,
speak and guide and and direct and
hoping that you're tuning in. And then
there's other moments where it feels
like even if you haven't asked that it
there's kind of like this spirit thing
that's happening where you feel like
you're being led and you're being, you
know, kind of like this work is
happening in your heart and you don't
even really know where it's coming from
or why it's coming. You know what I
mean? But it's just kind of like then
then you start tuning in. You know, it's
like in reverse. And this week, it just
felt like there was this um I don't I
don't know how to describe it except for
this like
still small voice, this kind of like
spirit-ledd thing that was happening as
for me a lot of times it happens like in
mashups of songs. like I, you know, I'll
be thinking on one song and then
suddenly another song starts weaving its
way in and then another song starts
weaving its way in and then I'm just
having this kind of like outpouring of
like my heart and and the feelings and
the emotions and the prayers that have
been kind of culminating over the last,
you know, I don't know, days or weeks.
And uh I I was having one of those
moments as I was getting ready for this
Sunday set. And um so after prayers of
the people today, we're going to have a
little mashup of sorts. That's probably,
you know, I don't know. I don't know if
it will speak to anyone else the way
that it spoke to me, but I wanted to
just give you guys that little window
into like sometimes God speak to speaks
to us in weird ways. At least at least
for me, it's it's not always the ways
that I expect it to come. And sometimes
it's not when I expect it or when I want
it. Um but I want to be tuning in. I
want to be in a posture of listening and
receiving and and trying to interact
with this divine force of love and
creativity and beauty that I really do
believe and hope is always guiding us,
holding us, calling us forward. And um
this passage in Romans
came to my mind this week while I was
preparing. And it says, "For those who
are led by the spirit of God, they are
children of God. The spirit you received
did not make you a slave so that you
live in fear again. Rather, the spirit
you received brought about your
adoption.
And by him we cry, "Aba, father." The
spirit himself testifies with our spirit
that we are his children. And now if we
are children, then we're hes
of God, co-airs with Christ. if indeed
we share in his suffering so that indeed
we may also share in his glory. So
tonight I hope that we can take that
place as a child of God as a daughter, a
son, a beloved one that he is speaking
to. He is calling forward in whatever
way that may be for you. Maybe it's in
songs, maybe it's out in nature, or
maybe it's going about your daily work.
But I pray that tonight we would tune
our hearts to what his voice might be
doing, might be stirring in us, what he
might be turning our attention towards
so that we can interact with this force,
this source of love, this source of
goodness and hope and see what he might
have to say to us tonight.
You guys can follow along with Caitlyn
on this first song. She's going to lead
us and we're going to start with Psalm
116.
[Music]
I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered me.
for you have delivered my soul from
death, my feet from stumbling. I will
walk in the land of the living, my soul
from death, my feet from stumbling. I
will walk in the land of the living.
[Music]
I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered me.
[Music]
I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered my soul from
death, my feet from stumbling. I will
walk in the land of the living, my soul
from death, my feet from stumbling. I
will walk in the land of the living.
[Music]
I will bless you, Lord, for you heard my
cry. I reach out my hand and you save my
life. I will bless you, Lord, for you
heard my plea. And the God of heaven
turned his ear to me. And I will bless
you, Lord, for unending love, for your
grace and mercy raining down from above.
I will bless you, Lord, till the very
end. I will call on you as long as I may
live. And I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered me.
I love you, Lord,
for you have delivered my soul from
death, my feet from stumbling. I will
walk in the land of the living. My soul
from death, my feet from stumbling. I
will walk in the land of the living.
[Music]
All right, kiddos. You guys are
dismissed to go to your classes. Your
teachers will meet you over by the
doors.
Thank you guys so much.
Me and Lisa, Maggie
and Abigail
[Music]
and we're going to transition to the
prayers of the people. So, if you guys
would follow along on the screens and uh
we'll read the parts in red aloud
together.
Jesus, for the city of Saxi, Texas, and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it. We
pray to you for the old and the sick,
the widow and the orphan, the injured
and the suffering. We pray to you for
the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So we lift
these names and situations up to you.
[Music]
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may receive life and light,
healing and hope, peace, and a deep
sense of your presence. Amen.
All this pain.
I wonder if I'll ever find my way.
I wonder if my life could really change
at all.
[Music]
No,
this earth
could all that is lost ever be found.
Could a garden come up from this ground
at all?
[Music]
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of dust.
You make beautiful things out of us.
[Music]
All
around
hope is springing up from this old
ground.
Out of chaos, life is being found
in you.
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of dust.
You make beautiful things out of us.
Oh, you make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of us.
Oh.
Oh,
[Music]
you make me new. You are making
me new.
You make me new. You are making
You make
me
You
think out of me.
You make me new. You are
set me.
Oh, you make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of dust.
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of us.
[Music]
Oh.
Ooh.
You make me new. You are making
me new.
[Music]
You make me new. You are making
me new.
We are leaving
crumbling buildings
full of dust and
full of judgement.
We are leaving
violent teaching
from those who refuse to learn from the
best of us.
We are leaving
crumbling buildings
full of dust and
full of judgement.
We are leaving
violent teaching.
Those who refuse to learn from the best
of us.
We are seeking
a holy healing.
It's full of hope and it's full of
justice. And I've got a feeling that
we're in the middle of it. I've got a
feeling she'll see us to the end of it.
We are seeking
a holy healing.
It's full of hope,
full of justice,
and I've got a feeling that we're in the
middle of it.
I've got a feeling she'll see us to the
end. I've got a feeling. And I've got a
feeling that we're in the middle of it.
I've got a feeling she'll see us to the
end of it.
I've got a feeling that we're in the
middle of it.
I've got a feeling she'll see us to the
end of it.
[Music]
Got a feeling she'll see us to the end
of it.
[Music]
By your spit I will
defeat
the resurrected king is resurrecting me
in your
life to declare your victory.
The resurrected king is resurrecting me.
By your spirit, I will rise from the
ashes of defeat.
The resurrected king is resurrecting me.
In your name, I come alive to declare
your victory.
The resurrected king is resurrecting me.
By your spirit I will rise from the
ashes of defeat. The resurrected king is
resurrecting me. In your name I come
alive to declare your victory.
The resurrected king is resurrecting
me.
He's resurrecting
Your name, your name is victory.
All praise will rise through Christ our
king.
Your name, your name is victory.
Oh praise will rise to Christ our king.
Oh praise to praise to Christ our king.
Your name, your name is victory.
Oh, praise will rise to Christ our king.
By your spirit, I will rise from the
ashes of defeat.
The resurrected king is resurrecting me.
In your name I come alive to declare
your victory.
The resurrected king is resurrecting
me.
Is resurrecting
He's resurrecting
me.
[Music]
You're resurrecting
me.
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of dust.
You make beautiful.
[Music]
God, would you continue to speak to our
hearts,
to our dead bones,
and call us into new life?
Would you resurrect the die in weary
places.
[Music]
Would you do a new thing,
God? Lord, we trust that you can make
things new.
That there is grace,
that there is forgiveness,
there's redemption
in the name of Jesus.
And that by your spirit, we have the
opportunity to walk into a new
beginning.
Your word says that your mercies are new
every morning.
God, would we sense that
each day as we begin this week? Would
you help us to remember that your mercy
is new
and your voice is alive.
It is speaking to our hearts. It's
calling out.
Would we have ears to listen?
[Music]
Would we have a soft heart?
Would we be ready to follow?
We love you, Jesus, because you are
good,
because you are faithful,
and because you do not desert the work
of your hand.
You don't give up on us.
[Music]
Keep doing your good work. It's in Jesus
name we pray. Amen.
[Music]
All right, you guys can turn to the
person beside you and say, "The peace of
Christ be with you."
Well, grace and peace. It is uh it is
good to see all your faces. My name is
Brett. I'm the pastor here. Pronouns he
he him and uh yeah, a joy joy to be with
you all. And as always, that includes
those join us online. Love you all lots.
Don't forget your communion elements for
later in the service. We'd love for you
to participate with us in that. Um and
also a uh a warm welcome to anyone here
who's new. If this is your first time or
just your first time in a long time,
we're really really glad that that
you've joined us. And I know how much
courage it can take to come through
those double doors depending on church
backgrounds and histories and stories
and all that. Just
it can be a lot. So, um yes, we're
really glad that that you're with us.
So, um we are let's see this is the the
seventh and really the it's the final um
sermon in this series that we're in
right now entitled Enchanted: Reclaiming
Sacred Ground in a Disenchanted World.
Uh next week we're going to have a bit
of like a roundt um discussion just kind
of going through it's been you know a
long series and we've covered a lot of
ground so we'll be kind of uh just
processing through uh how it hit folks
and what some of our takeaways are and
and all that. Um so that'll be next
week. So that's why this is the last um
at least sermon in the series. And uh
the the kind of premise of the series is
that we we live in a kind of
increasingly um secular culture that you
know where in essence uh sort of god
religion um it's still of course
prevalent but it's sort of privatized
you know I mean it's kind of there for
your like personal life and uh it is
sort of increasingly shunned from the
the public sphere and uh because of that
because we were kind
uh those big stories that we've made
since the world
uh called you know religious stories as
those kind of get pushed to the uh the
sidelines kind of the unintended side
effect we actually covered last week in
a series on politics I think the the
kind of upside to having like separation
of church and state and such that's
really important um but the some of the
downside is some of the stuff we've been
going uh kind of hitting on in this
series um things like where sort of the
you're kind of draining the a sense of
the sacred the kind of depth dimension
uh out of uh so much of life. And so
we've kind of in the series we've been a
little bit all over the place. We talked
about truth, we talked about uh sex. Um
we're last week like I mentioned was
politics. We talked about relationships.
And um this week we're going to be
talking uh about the arts. And so the
title of my message is rediscovering the
beautiful. And our scripture is from the
very first chapter of the Bible. Genesis
chapter 1 uh verse 27 which reads so God
created human beings in his own image in
the image of God he created them.
The uh the famous 20th century
theologian Hanzer von Baltazar that's a
mouthful right there. That's a fun it's
a fun name to say. uh he placed beauty
of all things, beauty right at the heart
of his theology. And uh he did this
basically because he said, you know, we
we kind of really he was kind of tuning
into the the kind of growing tide of
secularism. And he said, we do we live
in a kind of day and age where folks
have lost faith in like truth. Uh folks
have lost some faith even in goodness.
You know, who's to say what's really
good? And he said, "I wonder if perhaps
in that kind of culture where, you know,
I mean, if you can just imagine someone
getting up like on the street corner
with the Bible in their hands saying
like, well, I've got the truth right
here." You know, I mean, like, how's
that going to go down? You know, I mean,
of course, everyone who's already like
an insider or something like Christian
fundamentalism be like, "Yeah, finally."
You know, taking a stand of truth, but
that's not going to be some genius
on-ramp to the broader culture. You know
what I mean? like it that's precisely
what's being questioned is the truth of
the you know what I mean so you can't
just assume like u so he said for that
reason um I wonder if perhaps beauty
maybe beauty could be like an on-ramp uh
for folks back to um a sense of wonder
back to mystery back to God and
ultimately perhaps for some like even
back to Christ uh and yet he knew though
that even kind of in this day and age
but even our faith in beauty though was
sort of uh fading a bit. So he has this
uh this quote. He says, "We no longer
dare to believe in beauty and we make of
it a mere appearance in order the more
easily to dispose of it. Our situation
today's today shows that beauty demands
for itself at least as much courage and
decision as do truth and goodness and
she will not allow herself to be
separated and be banned from her two
sisters without taking them along with
herself in an act of mysterious
vengeance.
That's a kind of interesting idea, isn't
it? That in essence once beauty goes
then truth and goodness go too. which is
we often don't think this is uh
theologians have talked often about how
these are the transcendentals right
beauty truth goodness and how they're
like kind of locked together like in
other words how do you know that
something is true like where you just
have a kind of like I that is like
resonating with me like I really think
that's true well part of it is beauty
right there's something it's sort of
elegant in the form of it it's sort of
balanced and you're
Yeah, that resonates, right? There's
something there's there's something
beautiful about the truth. Similar with
goodness. How can you spot goodness?
Well, part of it is the beauty of a good
life, right? We're kind of drawn to
people with a goodness in their heart.
There's a there's a a certain beauty
that resonates um about them. He
continues, "We can be sure that whoever
sneers at Beauty's name as if she were
the ornament of a bourgeoa pass, that'
be like upper crust, upper class, you
know, past, whether he admits it or not,
can no longer pray and soon will no
longer be able to love."
Well, what's beauty got to do with love
and prayer? Well, again, it's because of
those transcendentals, right? Truth,
beauty, goodness, all kind of hanging
together. And in fact, those themselves,
they're rooted in God. Uh when I went
through my own kind of deconstruction
years, was that 15 years ago or so now?
Uh and I was like, I didn't know what
way was up. You know, I don't know if I
believe in God. I'm not sure. I
certainly can't do this Christian hot
mess of a thing anymore. I just, you
know, I just don't I didn't know which
way was up. Um when I was in kind of my
darkest days though, something that
really helped me through was
beauty.
uh and truth and goodness, but beauty.
Like what I found was I kind of had this
intuition that like these things really
matter and I cannot live without them. I
just can't get away from I need I crave
like I'm hungry for beauty, truth,
goodness. Like I just and in essence it
was almost like those were the signposts
pointing me back to God. Does that make
sense? Like in other words, some people
reverse that, you almost like, well,
first let me prove or something or have
or really know that God exists and then
from there I might have a go at like
maybe there is some beauty or truth or
goodness in the world because God, you
know, I'm convinced of God. Uh, and I I
don't know, at least for me, it was the
other way around. This is why um I could
even imagine like a more secular person
maybe asking like why should I believe
in Christ? you know, all the bad
religions done and such. I just why
should I do this, you know, and uh at
least to me at that moment when when
there's, you know, they're kind of in
that skeptical place just like when I
was there, uh kind of purely
intellectual arguments
at times they fall a little bit flat,
you know, like in essence, if I gave
them a book like, well, here read
Aquinus's proofs for God's existence,
you know, or or here here read this
book. this this proves the resurrection
of Jesus. You know, I I don't know. I
mean, maybe maybe for some that could be
really helpful and like just what they
need. But I suspect for most it's like,
you know, that that's not really so so
helpful. Um and and why is this? I I
think it's because beauty uh it's
actually beauty that often comes first.
In other words, we're wooed.
recalled by Christ, right? It's the it's
the form of his life that is so gosh
darn beautiful. Like it just it's just
lovely. It's just and there's such a
truth and a goodness about him that
we're just like yes, you know, we just
kind of find ourselves believing and
then from there you can continue to work
out intellectually the things you need
to work out, right? And so I'm not
saying there's no place for the the
intellect or thinking or whatever. Uh
but in essence, I think beauty has to
come first, right? It's the it's the
lure, we might say, of beauty. God
doesn't force us. God calls, God draws
us. And yet, as Baltazar kind of hints
at in a secular world, right, all of
this starts coming kind of into
question. you know, not sure about God,
not sure about truth, not sure about the
good, and not sure about beauty. And uh
you can see uh that in like in essence
as we start to kind of lose our faith in
that um
suddenly
kind of our vision of what is beautiful
and our and our hope even for like the
arts and such starts to kind of wither
and diminish. Like people start to
wonder um you know why can't art just be
ugly? you know, why does music need to
have I mean, yes, there's a place of
course for dissonance and such, but then
there's always that resolution, you
know, but why why have the the sense of
harmony or resolution? Why shouldn't
painting or literature be random or
chaotic or downright evil, you know? Or
maybe like why maybe art really is just
functional,
you know? Maybe it really is like maybe
it's just there to serve political
interests, right? Right? It's just there
to get an agenda across. It's it's the
it's just to pritify it, you know, kind
of pretty it up and make it palatable to
people. Maybe that's what the arts do.
Uh or even business and marketing
interests. Maybe that's that's kind of
what the arts are. They're they're
really just there to serve those things.
You know, why shouldn't art be about
lies and propaganda? Why should art be
true and good? So you can see where like
if you just kind of think of history of
the 19th 20th century and such, you
know, art becomes kind of increasingly
at least in places in a way kind of
abstract or ugly. Uh music increasingly
dissonant, chaotic, poetry more
fractured, if anyone even reads poetry
anymore. Uh literature less concerned
with drawing folks towards the good and
the true. And uh to be clear, I wouldn't
at all say like, oh, in the 20th
century, you know, the arts have just
fallen to pieces. there is no good art
anymore or I'm not trying to be that
dramatic. What I would say though is
this. Only to the degree that artists
resist the philosophies and perspectives
of the secular will they retain their
inner vitality and calling.
I think this is why if you go back
through history and like some great art
like it's often right um it's not
necessarily religious art per se in the
sense of oh it's a picture of Jesus you
know but it's it's it's often from it's
a from a deeply religious culture right
that still has this deep belief in faith
right yes in God but also in truth and
goodness and beauty and they're all kind
of hanging together right and that
infuses and that um kind of draws up or
or calls forward really beautiful art. I
think of, you know, in at least in kind
of Christian culture, Michelangelo's
statue of David, uh Da Vinci's famous
Last Supper, um which remember at our at
our old community, the church we used to
meet at, they had this reproduction of
Da Vinci's Last Supper there, which I
think they just bought from China for,
you know, like a few hundred bucks or
something, but it always kind of pained
me. But you can see what it's kind of
hinting at. I mean, there is something
good there or Beethoven's Ode to Joy,
you know, comes to mind. And again, not
that these artists were like they were
all great Christians or No, no, I'm just
saying that the the broader culture,
right, that kind of brought these works
about uh was a deeply religious culture
and in this case a Christian kind of
culture. Uh you'll recall we talked in a
sermon a few weeks ago on creation about
a sacramental view of the world and I
think that really comes into play here.
So what's a what's a sacrament? So a
sacrament is anything that both points
to and participates in divine mysteries.
So what is a sacramental understanding
of the world? Well, that is to say all
creation, right? Everything, everyone is
actually sacramental. In in essence, all
of it points to all of it participates
in the divine. And so, can you see where
that kind of view like what that would
do to the arts,
right? It starts to kind of reinfuse,
reinvigorate, re-enliven them. They kind
of get their mojo back. They regain
their confidence in clarity because
suddenly we see uh art is not just some
purely functional endeavor. It's not
just there to serve some sort of
business or political interest. uh
what's going on there? It's a deeply uh
spiritual act, right? To be a maker is
to connect with the sort of capital M
maker, right? To come back to Genesis
1:27, we could say uh so God created
human beings in his own image, in the
image of God. He created them, right? So
here you have God as like the original
artist. And now as human beings, part of
what it means for us to be made in that
divine image is what that we too create,
right? We too uh we make
and in that way um like in that very act
in essence is deeply spiritual, right?
That is it's sacramental. In other
words, we could kind of sum it up by
saying the artist's primary allegiance
is not to being shocking or appealing to
the market or even being faithful to
personal expression. Rather, the
artist's allegiance is to the spirit of
God flowing in and through all things.
In other words, to be creative is not
the same as being smart.
Right? The smart person knows a lot of
things. The artist may or may not know a
lot of things or have, you know, some
high IQ or something. But what the
artist has is, as I've said before, a
good antenna,
so to speak, right? This is someone who
uh can tune in. The Greeks called it the
muse, right? You go through every
culture and like this is of course how
they thought of it, right? Making art
was a divine thing. Why? Because if
you've ever made anything, you know it's
a weird process. You're like sometimes
you it's it's well maybe I could um say
in essence uh like the artist is not
quite the source of their work. Does
that make sense? At least really good
art. The artist isn't the pure source.
Of course, the artist is involved. Uh
but you could see the the artist is more
like a a conduit, the one to bring forth
what they sense God desires to be
created.
And so seeing from this perspective, I
would say creating, making, painting,
sculpting, you know, any form of art is
it's it's almost more like giving birth,
right? to use that maybe a weird
metaphor. I don't know. But it's almost
more like that than like solving a
problem.
Uh what I mean is like if you listen to
artists, you know how they talk like
they often talk about how the the poem
it was like growing within them for a
day or a week or a year or a decade or
more,
right? It was it was coming. The
painting had to kind of grow and they
had they were sensing they were feeling
their way intuiting with the Holy
Spirit. I would say as a Christian like
with the spirit what is this thing
that's trying to come forth uh from me?
uh even the way like a like a sculptor
doesn't uh force their will on the the
thing whether like the piece of marble,
you know, it's not just like I have a
vision and here we go just hacking away,
you know what I mean? Like no, no, no.
They know they have to like work with it
and they have to kind of It's almost
like I've heard sculptor say it's almost
like they're they're releasing
the sculpture that they can see and
sense. They're releasing it from the
marble.
Does that make sense? Maybe that just
strikes you as completely woowoo and
weird, but it makes perfect sense to me.
Like where in essence it's again it's
not about their will, right? But there's
a sense of something's trying to come
forth here. Uh in the same way the uh we
might say that like the spirit kind of
has to to guide the potter's hands, you
know, as they feel that clay and sense
what is being made here. And the
finished product is a revelation
not only to the audience, you know, to
us or something, but even to the artists
themselves, to the maker. Right? If
you've ever created something and then
been surprised at what it was you
created, you know, or you started down
this direction and then ended up going
over here. Why? You had a plan. Follow
the plan. I was like, well, that's not
really how art works, right? You're
there's a sense of following the spirit
here. The wonderful Christian composer
Arvo Part. And uh if you haven't
listened to him, you gota I mean he's
like he is literally the most performed
composer in the world today. And he's a
Christian like an incred I mean
incredible. And of course almost no
Christians know him which is really you
know because he is he's a Christian or
he's a artist who happens to be a
Christian you know I mean I suppose like
trying to even though he does even
religious type type music but um anyway
he said he said this at at the time when
my music came into existence I was in
search of a little island of sound
in search of a place in my innermost
being where shall we say a dialogue with
God might take place.
finding this place became a task of
vital importance to me. Can you kind of
hear the language there where he's he's
needing this interaction with God? In
fact, knowing his story, he went through
actually a long season like years and
years and years where he could not
compose a word or or write a write a
note um anything. He couldn't do
anything. It was like the season of
silence in his life. It was incredibly
difficult for him. Why? because the
spirit was not speaking,
right? The thing it wasn't his time,
right? You can see there where there's
that lack of kind of control. This is
this is kind of the the spiritual nature
of what art is all about. And this is
why I think, right, the secular can
really kind of hinder this whole process
because this all becomes just woowoo and
weird and like stupid and not real. You
know what I mean? It's only to the
degree again that artists kind of resist
that that kind of um secular impulse
that they can continue to kind of
flourish. Uh the famous music producer
Rick Rubin, he's been making all the
social media rounds recently like his
book. I don't know if you all have seen
it, but um he uh so he spent a lifetime
like helping musicians basically give
expression to their work. And uh he said
something very similar. He said this
making art is a mystical process. A lot
of people who are artists don't
understand it themselves, especially the
young ones. They feel different,
but they don't know what it is. They
feel more. Everything hurts. Everything.
They're super sensitive. They see things
that other people don't see. It can be
crippling for someone like Kurt Cobain.
It can kill you.
He continues, "This is a different
occasion." He said, "Art is all an
offering to God. If you're making an
offering to God, you're not thinking,
"What's the budget?"
or, "I hope this segment of the audience
is going to like it." We don't think
like that. We're making the best we can
make to the best of our ability out of
love and devotion.
That's what it is. There is no higher
form.
As far as I know, Rick Rubin is not a
Christian, but you can hear in all that,
I mean, that religious language and that
spiritual kind of impulse in him, right?
He knows like, no, no, this is what
great art is about. This is what
creativity. You have to plug into
Genesis 1:27, right? The the divine,
you've got to be tapped into that to
make great things.
I think um you know this perspective
gaining more widespread traction is I I
think really could like lead to a what
we might call a revitalization
uh a reinvigoration of the arts in um
our culture. And I believe this is
actually what Rubin's talking about,
what Arvart's talking about. I think
this is what makes something a quote
unquote, you know, Christian or godly or
spiritual work of art. Uh, this is also
why I don't listen to much so-called
Christian music or watch many so-called
crappy Christian movies. Um,
and
you know, and it's it's honestly for
that reason that even certain forms of
secular kind of quoteunquote secular art
that aren't doing what Reuben's talking
about, right? That themselves, like if
maybe Christian artists are very focused
on like, well, I hope this really
connects with the conservative Christian
audience. Is anything in this going to
possibly maybe offend some, you know
what I mean? Like, let me what was a
banger last month? Let me just try to
reproduce that thing. You know, that to
the degree that that happens, right? Not
just in Christian music or something,
right? You go the secular version of
that of like, oh, let's write another
hit like that last hit. Let's do another
thing, you know what I mean? Um, I'll
get in trouble, but let's make another
Marvel movie. You know what I mean?
Like, let's reproduce. Just keep the
thing going, you know what I mean? Um,
that will run itself out. That will that
will lose, you know what I mean? At
first, it's fresh and new and the
spirit's moving and it's a great, you
know what I mean? And after like 15
years, it's kind of like, okay, this is
we're a little spin here, you know,
we're we're um yeah, I might not make it
out alive at this, but I don't know.
The the thinker Francis Schaefer um he
put it like this. He said, "I'm afraid
as evangelicals, we think that a work of
art only has value if we reduce it to
attract."
Right? In other words, it better say
Jesus, right? Or it better uh tell the
gospel or something. But can you kind of
see in everything I've been naming
though that a person's art can say Jesus
a lot, you know, but uh if if they
themselves though were obsessed with
what's my audience going to think or
what you know I mean that in essence if
they themselves weren't really tuned
into the spirit and it wasn't an
offering to God then I don't care how
many times it says Jesus.
uh it it just might not connect. You
know what I mean? The spirit might not
really be um in the thing.
Yeah. Because in essence, we need it to
be this act of love and devotion. This
little side note, this is also why I
have zero interest in like AI music and
such, you know, uh because it's it's
just um or AI art, you know what I mean?
Because it's I guess I get it for like
the business world. I guess maybe that's
its own conversation. Um, but when it
comes to the arts, it's just not what
it's not what it's about, right? We've
got to it's this whole process uh that
we've been discussing like that's uh
what I think really matters in in art.
That's what I'm always interested in.
Like what how was the spirit speaking to
this person? How was God leading them
towards beauty, truth, and goodness?
That's what I'm curious about. You know
what I mean? Not just like technically
like certain sounds or something. So, my
dream uh and perhaps it's a little bit
far-fetched, but in closing, my dream is
that the church could again be a source
of inspiration, of support, of love for
the arts and for artists. My dream is
that we could rediscover a sacramental
view of the world that understands all
art as creators reflecting
our creator. My dream is that Christians
could come alive again as we resist a
culture which is tempted to sneer at
beauty and instead we could begin to
find healing for ourselves as we drink
in the beautiful each day and give
ourselves over to making beautiful
things. I even reimagine or I even dream
of reimagining the church and its
services as acts of beauty
rather than as purely functional things.
And what if beauty is our on-ramp back
to God?
For all my friends deconstructing, just
not sure of God. You know, what if
beauty is your on-ramp?
For all those who today you just feel
far from God. What if beauty is your
on-ramp, your path back to God? Or for
those who feel just I've never been
close to Christ. I just never felt what
people are talking about. You know,
maybe beauty is is your path.
Because what if you could know that when
you take in the beautiful, it's a
reflection of what? Of who? It's a
reflection of the glory of God. The God
who is father, son, spirit.
So, if you're looking for a takeaway
from this message, I would say I think
there's really just two. Um, one is if
you're a maker, well then get out there
and make. You know, you're like an
artist. You got that impulse, that thing
in you like you do it. You do it. And
maybe it will say Jesus, you know, or
something or maybe not, but it doesn't
that's that's not the delineating
factor. Is this Christian or is this
spiritual or is it No, no, no. If it's
good art, it is spiritual. So I say get
out there may and and uh you have our
support and our love and uh man, I wish
the church could uh not just the table
but the broader church do better like
encouraging artists and uh having them
flourish. So, um, so that's the first
thing for those who are here like, well,
I'm not an artist or I'm not a maker,
you know, whatever. Uh, I would say
encourage you this week. Uh, take in the
beautiful.
Take it in. Do do something you wouldn't
normally do. Whether it's taking a
little extra time like in a garden and
just really looking, really seeing. Um,
whether it's maybe like taking time to
actually listen to a whole album of
music from start to finish. I know, wild
ideas, right? Like who's who does that
anymore? No one got time for that. Uh
going to an art gallery. I mean, just
whatever, you know? But just take in the
beauty around you because if you have
the eyes to see, like it really is all
around us. So
my hope is um
that
as we kind of deepen um our own love,
the beautiful, I I my hope is that our
souls to can be deepened and that our
faithfulness to Christ to the God who is
love can grow and grow and in that way
our light can begin to shine before
others such that they too are drawn to
the beauty of Christ. In the name of the
father, the son and the holy spirit.
Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it. And he said,
"Take it, eat. This is my body. It's
broken for you." And then he held up a
cup of wine. He said, "Take it. Drink.
This is my blood. It's shed for you.
Whenever you eat this bread, whenever
you drink this cup, remember me." So as
we come forward, we're participating in
that divine mystery, the very presence
uh of Christ here among us through the
spirit. Uh the way we'll participate in
communion tonight, we'll just go rowby
row. We'll start here at the front and
just form one line here in the middle
and uh when one group's kind of done,
the the next row can go ahead and uh
jump in line. We practice what's called
an open table. Meaning, if you're here
tonight and you'd like to participate,
then you are free to do that regardless
of your, you know, denominational
affiliation or theology or beliefs or
whatever. Um, if you if you want to
connect with the risen Christ, then
you're you're free to do that. Uh, you
should know the red is wine, the white
is grape juice. And finally, you can
just partake whenever and however you'd
like. Some folks like to come forward
and kneel. Some partake immediately,
some return to their seats to partake.
You can um just do that kind of at your
own kind of desire. So this is the table
not of the church but of the Lord and
it's made ready for you love him and for
those who want to love him more. So come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long. You who
have tried to follow and you who feel
like you failed. Come. Come because it's
the Lord Jesus himself who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here. Come to
the table.
[Music]
If you guys want to stand with us, we're
going to end um going back to beautiful
things and let's just invite in um that
trust that God is creating and we
are conduits like Brett said and uh
let's just open ourselves up to the
beautiful thing that he's doing in each
one of us.
All
around.
Hope is springing up from this old
ground.
Out of chaos, life is being found
in you.
[Music]
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of dust.
You make beautiful things out of us.
You make beautiful things.
You make beautiful things out of dust.
You make beautiful things out of us.
Oh,
[Music]
you make me new. You are making
Make me new.
[Music]
You make me new. You are making
me new.
[Music]
Thank you for joining us tonight. Um, if
you're a visitor for the first time or
maybe just a few times and you haven't
filled out a visitor card yet, um,
there's some on the little table over
there or you can do it online with the
QR code that's on the screen. We'd
really just love to know that you were
here. So, if you could take that few
seconds to do that, that would be great.
Second, if this is your church home or
you enjoy the ministry here and you find
it beneficial, um take a moment and uh
maybe think about giving. You can do
that at the QR code, too. Um that's
always welcome. Um
third,
um ministry teams. Um the summer always
makes it a little skinny around here for
those of us that help out. Um, but we're
always looking for people with open
hearts and open minds that want to uh
help out in any way, whether that's
artistically or um just standing up here
and do what I do and talking a lot. Um,
we'd love to have you on the team. So,
you can do that at the QR code as well.
Um, finally, I'd like to send you into
your week with a benediction and a
blessing.
You are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day and it's true on your
worst day. So as you go into your week
ahead with its yet to be determined
highs, lows, and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved.
You are worthy and you are accepted just
as you are.
Go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend those same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed
this week and we'll see you back here
next Sunday.
[Music]
You make me new. You are making
me new.
Oh.
[Music]
Where is it?